Well,
the other,
the other element is very important to this is music is the voice of a
subculture.
So when you tell 100 million kids who filled out early,
isolated and alone,
that they,
that their experiences had not been reflected in the experience of any other
person on earth,
that in fact they are not alone.
Layer a movement.
You give a subculture,
a boys and you can see that with,
well,
when I finally got into working with music,
one of the first things I did was work with country and western music.
Now George,
uh,
I worked with a company called doc records.
I was hired by a Gulf and western to found a public and artist's relations
department for their 14 record companies.
And one of those companies was not records and dot.
Records was number three on the country charts and that it was with third place
company and they wanted to be number one,
uh,
in country and western music.
Now when I was a child,
when I was about three and a half years old,
I woke up on a Sunday before anybody else in the house had woken up,
went out to the front room where there was sunlight,
which I didn't get to see as often as I'd like and turned on the radio and
because it was six o'clock in the morning or something like that,
what I got were farm reports and country and Western music.
This was in 19 1946 or something like that,
or 1947 and I immediately knew
that that music was alien to me and I knew that it was the music of another
subculture would not necessarily be kind to the subculture from which I came.
So I never liked country music
in the 1970s when I got this position with Gulf and western,
one of the things I crusaded for the hardest was country and western music
because I felt that these people had a right to express their identity.
I felt they had a right to get beyond the ghetto of the Bible belt,
which is where they were kept.
And where are they were suppressed.
It was an era of subculture is finding themselves and expressing their right to
exist.
It started
music really does seem to have that binding capacity.
You know,
I think there's also something neurological about that because to tell me what
you think about this,
if this is in accordance with your observations,
but it seems to me that the music that people listen to as their catalyzing
their adult identity,
say between the ages of about 14,
15 to 20,
you know,
there's a,
there's a real intense
mmm
period of neural pruning that occurs at the end of adolescence.
So you'll get none this amount of neural neural pruning after,
uh,
after you're born in the early stages of infancy,
cause you have a lot of neural connections and then a lot of them,
you kind of dye into your childhood self,
right?
You're,
you're born with twice as many neurons as you will actually need.
Right?
Right.
Exactly.
And so,
so you're,
you're a mass of possibility.
And then you dye into your actuality.
And then that happens again in late adolescence,
right?
Which is also in schizophrenia develops because that process seems to go wrong
for some people.
But as you're diving into that adult identity,
one of the things that seems to catalyze that is the music of your culture at
that time.
And that also seems to unite you in some way underneath rational thought with
the people of your generation,
let's say with the people you'd have to cooperate with and compete with.
And so there's something really deep about that too.
That's not well understood.
And,
and,
and so
I,
well,
so I don't know what you think about the second element of that because it's a
brilliant observation.
And then the second element of that is that in your late teens,
your prefrontal cortex gets wired up.
Now what's the pre frontal cortex?
It's pro.
We talk about it as the,
the center of Administration in the brain executive functions.
It's primary job is making you human.
What does that mean?
You would think that means encouraging certain things like creativity and
thought,
no,
the job of the prefrontal cortex and making you human
is
press things.
Um,
it's too damp things down.
It's to inhibit things and you are learning which things to inhibit after you
become utterly grafted into your subculture.
And what is one of the elements that has grafted you when do your subculture
music?
And so what Freud would call the Super Ego is formed to a certain extent based
on your subculture,
where connections that you've developed as a team and again use it helps
identify that subculture of which you feel apart.
Right?
Well,
okay.
So,
so partly what's happening there is that because music is poetic and also it's
poetic and emotional,
let's say,
it also constitutes the,
the pre rational substrate from which the values of that subculture emerge.
So it's like the,
it's part of the mythological substructure of the values of that culture.
And you can make absolute sense.
Yeah.
You can see that expressed in the lyrics in,
right.
And where,
which lay out a system of values in some sense.
Right?
Something like hip hop for example.